uh
so
uh i'm gonna tr what happened earlier
was that i tried to invite some people
in and then the screen went white and i
couldn't shut it down i couldn't get
back to the discussion in the end i
closed down chrome
i think that sent all of the original
participants off to bed
uh while i tried to figure out how to
get the thing back up again
uh but here we are so we lost we managed
to discourage
three or four other people
but we have the core group here now so
we will continue so i'm gonna try to
screen share
and i hope i don't mess up here okay and
i'm going to go through some of the i am
as a user at link nicholas are you a
link user
yeah yeah okay
what's your username at link
it's
n i c k
for ease and age
okay that's complicated i won't try to
remember i'm gonna try to screen share
here and we'll see what happens
okay so if i try this looks well google
hangout desktop which one google
plus boy select window
all right
holy cow can you see that what a mess
what are we supposed to do with that
that doesn't look very good
uh
let's try here okay
now
there we go
shut this guy down
go away
how does this come up all the time i
want to be here
just a second we're gonna shut down
okay now go back here
boy it still does that
hmm
i wonder how i am supposed to
ah
boy
in behind there is what i want to get at
which is our google which is our link
page but i've got this other garbage
showing up here
yeah
um
what happens now you do you see
you still see that mess
yes i know um
again
the mess is coming up yeah i know
what a ridiculous thing to have i mean
why not screen share and then just
choose a screen
why do you have all this other stuff
and i can't close that down
there all right so google hangouts
and i've only got one tab open
which is the link tab
and if i hit show
share what's on your screen click
here that's better
okay share selected okay how are we
doing now
hey all right okay
you can see my screen now
yes yeah all right
we are now in what we call the learn
page all right which is the first page
you come to
now
uh what you see at the learn page on the
right hand side
is
either recompen recommended lessons
now uh i should go to my so can you
still see it
yeah yes okay so here you have a drop
down list and you can
uh on this right hand side you can
either look at
lessons that have been recommended or
courses that have been recommended or
playlists that have been recommended
and what we mean by recommended is
that our learners have given
this lesson
or course or playlist arose
and so you'll see we normally put
the
the lesson that has just been given a
rose comes to the top
so here we have this podcast and espanol
from mexico by this set
so we see right away there's four people
who like this
it's got nine new words for me
now
when you first arrive
the um settings are not necessarily
accurate so let's say that you are an
intermediate one so you don't want to
see beginner one you only want to see
intermediate one and intermediate two
lessons so then
you click on the level of lessons that
you want to look at which let's say is
intermediate one and two so here we have
aprendamos espanol ethientias einstein
has 35 new words for me
or we can check out this lesson here
where berta talks to oscar
uh now we have these are our recommended
lesson
uh if we don't want any of these lessons
uh here are the ones that have have you
know various numbers of roses
then we can go to the library but let's
say we choose this lesson here
uh
we should have a look by the way on this
drop down list i could add this lesson
to a course
i could add it to a playlist do you
understand what a a course and a
playlist is
yes
okay emma do you understand
yes
okay i'll just go over because the
courses we've had them before like
people will load up um you know 10
lessons in a course
uh
but a playlist is new if you're going
through the library and you see
something of interest to you you may not
want to study it right away you can add
it to a playlist you might call this
playlist
these are good or it might be a playlist
of
if it's spanish you might say
mexico because you're interested in
mexico or spain or history
or if you're a tutor you might put
things in a playlist to help some of
your students
and you also have the option here to
share this on link to share it with
other members
uh to share it on facebook and share it
on twitter and so forth so but now we
open the lesson
and we'll go through the
the lesson page and you stop me when you
have any questions whatsoever
all right
all right
now here we have
the text is on the right hand side
and on the left we have a lot of
different information about this lesson
first of all we have here the sound bar
so we can listen to the lesson
and we can shut it down we can also go
back 10 seconds
we see that there are 35 new words
and five yellow words that we have this
is in this is my account right so for me
i have five words that i have already
started
studying and then we also can see what
resources are available for this lesson
the only resource available is the
tutorial and we recommend that everyone
do the tutorial just stop me whenever
you have a question right you can always
lots of view
tutorial okay
we go to the tutorial now one thing if
you click here you will see what
resources are available it could be that
translations are available it could be
that a video is available but in this
case the only thing available is a
tutorial
and the tutorial is simply a
one step at a time
tutorial on how to use link
so it says listen to the audio and try
to follow along the text right
and here it shows you where the audio is
so step two it has some further
instructions
and step three has further instructions
so all the tutorial is
is a detailed step through
uh of all of the different ways that you
can learn from link that's what the
tutorial does
okay
okay
so if we go back now to the information
details we see that there are 35 new
words we've got 122 known words
uh but let's start studying the lesson
okay we also know that it's 187
i don't know what 187 is
no what do you know it has 303 words
duration that's seconds minutes can't be
minutes okay
we start studying
and here
it is set to auto scroll so that if
some people like to move quickly through
the lesson
saving the words that they don't know
and the auto scroll moves you down the
page if you don't want to move down the
page you untick auto scroll
but i'm going to stay in auto scroll
right now
so we hit the first word andres
and it's a name you may not want to save
that
as a word
so if you hit x
whoops
if you hit x it goes over it and if you
hit x again whoops the x doesn't i
wonder if i'm connected here
hm
boy i wonder what's happening now
for some reason
i don't know whether the
in conjunction with this um
and with our um
that's strange
with the with this screencast it's not
working
just let me have make sure yeah
everything is plugged in
and for some reason the keyboard
shortcuts
are not working
okay we can't do that so you know what
i'm gonna have to let's get out of this